Mees anti-gay is an award-winning
screenwriter and producer she won the
n-double-a-cp Image Award for
outstanding writing in a motion picture
for Fox Searchlight spelt the script was
also nominated for a humanities Prize
Sega is producing and screenwriting
credits include secret laughter of women
and their Eyes Were Watching God
starring Halle Berry an executive
produced by Oprah Winfrey she is writing
Battersea rise for BBC and printed for
ITV adapting the life of Dame Daphne
Sheldrick life love and elephants and Fe
LA for Focus Features for the screen
meesa hello in these times when
everything and everyone seems motivated
by anger and hate and I include me in
that I found the perfect antidote
Joey Clarke script Joey has everything
that makes a great writer talent
persistence a strong and authentic voice
but what I love most about this script
was his characters and relationships
each character is real each relationship
is complex and however
flawed drawn with a deep understanding
it's a script with no easy villains just
what happens when your best isn't good
enough he's not afraid of some of the
more weighty issues of our times but
whereas we talk about the opioid crisis
often in terms of the person who's past
or the parents left behind he's talked
about what happens to a generation of
children it starts with a touching
portrait of parenthood love and wisdom
being passed from father to daughter but
right up there we have a devastating
loss because heroin can come for anyone
I was absolutely wrung out by this
opening I thought what is this game it
stirrings
the children are alone and even their
dog is in a pound and at every level the
system fails them love isn't what you
need it isn't what you have to give but
what is needed and the the system can't
cope with these two children I met Joey
and I asked him what motivated him to
write this script he said it was his
relationship with his sister except she
wasn't mean and I said well Timmy Riley
wasn't mean I hope she was me when the
world is upside down heartless
incomprehensible and uncaring she will
not give measure for measure when all
society's norms are abandoned she will
stand firm she will not abandon miles
the way the world is abandoned her she's
brave and angry she refuses to be cowed
or made callous a reminder that we have
to be fierce in our defense of kindness
decency and humanity in Riley he has
written a heroine for our times and I
loved his writing and I loved him too
because he was born in Missouri and he
started in California but like his
script every turn in his life has been
motivated by love love took him to
Colorado when he got married love took
him to Missouri back to Missouri when he
had a baby and all the time he kept
writing and when I spoke to him about
all of the wonderful opportunities that
would were going to come his way now I
noticed that the thing that made his
eyes light up was when he talked about
his son he's a man whose eyes shine when
he thinks about his boy and today he is
a nickel fellow Joey Clark
[Laughter]
thank you very much me sad for that's
some of the kindest words anybody's ever
said about me and me sod flew from
London a couple days ago to come say
them which is no one's ever flown across
an ocean to say anything about me
I want to thank our actors I was
fantastic I really appreciate that and I
think again that was also fantastic I
appreciate it um I want to thank Don and
G nickel for making this and keep it
going forever
I want to thank Joan why Chris cart J
and Jakob Richardson for running the
fellowship this week has been incredible
because of you guys in the last six
weeks where I've bothered you with all
my stupid questions and we're was also
very great you quick to answer
everything is very appreciative
I want to thank Robbins why cord and the
entire committee for thinking my script
and me were worthy of this opportunity
and this this incredible gift that
you're really giving us to to open the
door into into this community I want to
thank all the readers along the way and
in the nickel committee or the night the
committee but the the readers who
thought it was worth passing along to
the committee eventually as a writer you
kind of keep going not really knowing if
it's ever gonna lead to anything and and
you hope it will and you just tell
yourself a little because you want to
and it's it's a lot easier to go along
that journey when you have a family and
people supporting you and that starts
most with my beautiful wife Samantha
Samantha would really probably like
nothing more but than to have a normal
marriage where we put the kids to bed
and then hang out but she's willing to
sacrifice it so I can pursue this
nonsense and go right and I know it's a
big sacrifice for you and internally
grateful
I want to thank it's not even make sense
but I want my son Auggie he's not even
two so he doesn't know I'm talking about
but he's I mean without him I wouldn't
be standing up here so I would not have
really felt like I had a purpose to
really try to become someone that he
might look up to one day and try to be a
walking example hopefully of what you
can do if you work hard and have a
passion and surround yourself with good
people and you should also stop biting
me I want to I want to thank my mom and
her fiance Rick or up here from
Wilmington North Carolina taking a break
from hurricane rebuilding and I think my
mom has probably believed in me more
than anyone else and I probably don't
let you know enough how much that means
to me but it really does I mean a lot
next note
I want to thank my dad and stepmom Cindy
who Jill Clark the original I'm the
sequel a there they're here from st.
Louis and they've also always encouraged
me to keep going and I've said in the
past let's say it again if I would turn
out to be half the man my dad is I'll be
doing just fine
honest think Eric and Dana and I believe
ah nice is here and Dana sure is
watching with Erin in Kansas City I want
to thank you guys for always supporting
me and encouraging me and not you know
that saying you're not gonna do that I
want to thank all my in-laws who even
though I wanted to do this they said let
me marry their daughter or an sister and
last but not least I want to thank Kelly
and Ty are probably watching in Texas my
sister Kelly who as me son pointed out
no coincidence that I'm able to write
very close relationships between a
brother and sister and even even like
even if I said on the Facebook thing
like my sister kind of gets me more than
a lot of people a lot of people are
talking about this script I have a
favorite scene and then a lot of people
I talk to have a different favorite
scene and the one person who said my
favorite scene is this scene it was my
sister so I was like we still there talk
about what I like and well it's great to
have I'm trying to hurry up I'm sorry
well it's great to have family who's
always supporting you why not it's also
important to have people who actually
know what they're talking about reading
your stuff and saying keep going and
that starts that starts us Mike my good
man how he Kramer who's here somewhere
I've wanted to quit several times and
have quit several times and how he's
always there bringing me back in and how
he's the first person to read anything I
write and the only person who read miles
before I submitted it and I would not be
standing up here without Howie's
friendship I would not be up here
without the friendship of my buddy Matt
Taylor and Chicago either Matt and I
kind of fell in love with movies
together back when we were teenagers
going to a plaza Frontenac and tickly in
st. Louis and realizing my movies that
were there are good movies that don't
have to
you know be huge and there's a lot of
good small movies I'm not trying to say
I don't know and I want to thank there's
several other readers who read my stuff
and I've learned a lot from the notes
Tracy Mayer Sam's Lieberman Don Broda
and anyone else who's ever read anything
I've written at some point in my life I
really appreciate it and thank you all
very much